et en guadeloupe l'épidémie ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur 40 % des lits sont
occupés par les patients qu'aux vide à
la morgue est saturé 8 c'est lui
services du chu de pointe à pitre sont
enfermés pour accueillir des 1000
réanimation pour faire face à la
situation de nouveaux transferts de
malades ont lieu aujourd'hui vers les
métropoles à des renforts de soignants
seront aussi envoyés vendredi sur l'île
à des patients non vaccinés beaucoup
plus jeune que lors des trois premières
vagues selon patrick portecop chef du
samu au chu de pointe à pitre
les patients qui viennent maintenant
qu'ils se signalent aux régulations sont
pour beaucoup les patients beaucoup plus
jeune que lors des trois premières
vagues dépassant non vaccinés sur tout
et qui ont besoin d'être checker au
niveau des urgences pour décider de leur
abolition ou de soins à domicile
mais ceux qui sont réanimation sont
quasiment exclusivement les personnes
jeunes non vaccinés et d une moyenne
d'âge qui a diminué considérablement
et pour lesquels parfois reims mieux
nous arrivons trop tard sur le terrain
parce qu'ils ont eu le temps de faire un
arrêt cardiaque il ya aussi le fait que
nous ayons à faire maintenant à plus de
90% de contamination par ailleurs delta
qui lui-même être segment à fort pouvoir
de pénétration dans la population et
d'infections de sujets beaucoup plus
jeune et qui tombe malade beaucoup plus
vite par rapport à la cinétique nous
avons connu ici même et dans le reste du
monde donc cette fois ci la majorité des
patients est un facteur delta mais ils
on a une autre physionomie de la
population dans nos murs